ich möchte mich zunächst entschuldigen
für die kurze Verspätung ich dachte wir
sind damit direkt in den Bundestag
gekommen eben war noch ein bisschen
Verwirrung denn hier soll es um die
Finanzreform der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung geben als erstes
soll
Bundesminister der Gesundheit Karl
Lauterbach sprechen man musste ihn noch
finden jetzt ist er am Kult und wir
hören ihm gleich zu Regierung
hinterlassen hat ich möchte aber
ausdrücklich hier darauf hinweisen dass
ich dies nicht durchgängig kritisch sehe
weil wir sind in der letzten
Legislaturperiode in einer Situation
gewesen wo Strukturreformen schwer
durchzuführen waren wo vieles liegen
geblieben ist nicht möglich war und
daher ist das aus meiner Sicht
tatsächlich nicht wirklich vorzuwerfen
dass es zum Defizit kam aber es Defizit
muss behoben werden ich habe hier
vorgetragen ich glaube es auch ein Gebot
der Fairness wir haben mitregiert es gab
eine schwierige Zeit dass Defizite ist
entstanden wir müssen es jetzt beheben
aber nach hinten zu Blick lohnt sich
gegenseitig Vorwürfe zu machen das hilft
uns hier nicht weiter und das passiert
viel zu oft in diesem Haus
[Applaus]
die Grundmaxime der Reform die wir
angegangen sind war immer mit einem Wort
zu beschreiben keine
Leistungskürzungen in einer Lage in der
wdrzeit sind die gesetzlich
Krankenversicherten sie kämpfen mit der
Energiekrise sie kämpfen mit der
Inflation
sie wissen nicht ob die Gasversorgung
über den Winter komplett dargestellt
werden kann in einer solchen Situation
ist es nicht vertretbar dass
Leistungskürzungen vorgenommen werden
daher haben wir von vornherein
klargemacht es wird keine
Leistungskürzungen geben dieses
Versprechen haben wir einhalten können
des 17 Milliardendefizit wird hier
behoben ohne dass es in irgendeinem
Bereich der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung zu
Leistungskürzungen gekommen ist das ist
eine große Leistung dafür danke ich den
Abgeordneten diesen Weg mitzugehen
wir haben uns sogar überlegt wie können
wir aus dieser Not dass wir hier
Effizienzreserven gewinnen müssen noch
etwas herausholen im Sinne einer echten
Strukturreform da sind wir in zwei
Bereiche tiefer eingestiegen der erste
Bereich ist der
dass wir den Bereich der Arzneimittel
Versorgung ein Problem gelöst haben was
durch den Druck der Lobbygruppen über
viele Jahre nie gelöst werden konnte das
Problem lässt sich wie folgt beschreiben
in Deutschland ist es möglich und das
ist in Europa in keinem anderen Land
möglich mit Arzneimitteln auf den Markt
zu kommen die keinen gesicherten oder
nur einen sehr geringen Zusatznutzen
bringen im Vergleich zu bestehenden
Arzneimitteln aber trotzdem deutlich
mehr kosten zum Teil 50% Mehrkosten zum
Teil 100% Mehrkosten wir haben hier
tatsächlich im klassischen Sinne mit
einer Situation zu tun
die man heutzutage bezeichnet als eine
Situation der übergewinne die in der
Arzneimittel versorgen konnte im
sogenannten anox-system mit Medikamenten
an sehr hoher gewinnen gemacht werden
die keinen zusätzlichen Nutzen gebracht
haben oder nur sehr geringe nutzen aber
sehr hohe Preise das beseitigen wir
jetzt jetzt können diese Arzneimittel
nur eingebracht werden zu Preisen die
den bereits im Markt befindlichen
Arzneimitteln entsprechen und wieso
sollten wir ein Arzneimittel was nicht
besser ist deutlich besser bezahlen
dafür gibt es keinen Grund das haben wir
durchgesetzt und eine deutliche
Strukturreform im anox-system doch dafür
bin ich ganz herzlich dankbar
wir haben auch eine zweite
Strukturreform vorgenommen die ich für
wichtig halte jeder weiß dass die
sogenannte neupatientenregelung
eigentlich nur auf dem papierbestand und
häufig patientlich schon immer gab in
den Praxen als Neupatienten geführt
worden sind so dass wir hier Geld
ausgegeben haben mehr als eine halbe
Milliarde Euro pro Jahr ohne dass es zu
einer Verbesserung der Versorgung
gekommen ist das haben wir beseitigt
diese Regelung haben wir gestrichen was
wir stattdessen gemacht haben ist dass
jetzt die Patienten die schneller einen
Facharzttermin bekommen weil es einer
Überweisung gab oder war sie über die
terminservicestellen zum Fahrrad
gekommen sind dafür gibt es ein höheres
Honorar sowohl für den abgebenden
Hausarzt wie auch für den Facharzt der
schneller den Termin dann gibt seine
deutliche Verbesserung dass sein Schritt
in Richtung Abbau der zwei
klassenmedizin somit haben wir auch hier
eine Strukturreform geschaffen wir haben
im Prinzip die Analyse vorgetragen haben
gesehen die nordpatientenregelung wird
uns nicht weiter die schnelle Vergabe
von Facharzttermin werden wir der
Lichtstärke honorieren führt zu
schnelleren Terminvergaben das ist ein
wichtiger Schritt in Richtung des Abbaus
der unterschiedlichen Versorgung von
Privatpatienten und gesetzlich
Versicherten auch das ein Schichten die
richtige Richtung einer Verbesserung
eine Strukturreform im Rahmen eines
Gesetzes was das Defizit beseitigt hat
ich komme
ich komme zu den Bereichen wir haben bei
den Krankenkassen zum Teil erhebliche
Rücklagen noch gab die haben wir zuerst
überschätzt dann sind die genauer
abgeschätzt worden etwa 2,5 Milliarden
Euro das ist jetzt nicht die Zeit wo
Krankenkassen sich prunkvolle neue
Gebäude errichten oder Rückstellungen
für solche Gebäude sitzen sondern wo wir
tatsächlich an die Reserven herangehen
daher bauen wir diese Reserven ab ich
glaube wenn man das gesamte Gesetz
betrachtet dann sieht man das ein Gesetz
über welches fehlgesprochen wurde wo es
aber weniger Änderungen gegeben hat
zahlt wir das in das Kabinett gebracht
haben und den Bundestag wir haben lange
darüber diskutiert aber sein Gesetz wo
Effizienz Reserven abbauen wo wir den
Beitragssatz so wenig wie notwendig
erhöhen um 0,3 Beitragssatzpunkte wo wir
Rücklagen abbauen wo wir gleichzeitig
die
Arzneimittelversorgung und die
facharztversorgung verbessern einen
Gesetz aus meiner Sicht aus einem Guss
ich darf mich ganz herzlich für die
Erwartungen bedanken und glaube dass wir
damit einen wichtigen Schritt
weitergekommen sind um die GKV zu
erhalten in dieser Krise in der
kritischen Zeit aus das was sie ist
etwas was Stabilität ist und wo
Leistungskürzungen ausgeschlossen sind
und wo sukzessive die Versorgung der
gesetzlich Versicherten verbessern
vielen Dank wieder auch
der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach hat sich hier für die
Beratungen bedankt allein von der
Koalition gab es 17 Änderungsanträge die
hier mit eingearbeitet wurden also es
gab sehr viel Beratungsbedarf Tino Sorge
spricht nun als nächstes der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ich möchte Sie
heute beglückwünschen weil das ist die
erste Rede die wir hier im Plenum hören
wo sie nicht über das Thema Corona
gesprochen haben und das ist mehr Erfolg
glaube ich aber ich weiß gar nicht wo
ich wo ich anfangen soll und wo ich
aufhören soll also wir Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister ich kann es
Ihnen leider nicht ersparen wenn Sie
sich hier hinstellen und sagen
sie wollen das GKV-System stabilisieren
sie sagen das sei ein GKV
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz dann kann
ich Ihnen nur sagen das ist ein Problem
verschiebegesetz und das kann ich Ihnen
leider nicht ersparen die wir
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister und
das ist ja immer so dass sie dass sie
mittlerweile bei jeder Rede sagen sie
wollen ja nicht nach hinten schauen sie
wollen ihren Vorgänger nicht kritisieren
aber sie hätten alle Probleme sie hätten
die 17 Milliarden im System von der
Vorgängerregierung geehrt und da kann
ich nur sagen lieber lieber Herr Kollege
Lauterbach wer war denn in der letzten
und in der vorletzten Legislatur der
Fraktionsvize für den Gesundheitsbereich
wer saß denn immer mit am Tisch wer hat
denn die ganzen Gesetze die
gesellschaftlicher Konsens waren
Verbesserung in der Pflege Verbesserung
bei den Ärzten schnellerer
Facharzttermine wer hat das denn
mitgeschlossen da saßen sie doch am
Tisch und sich jetzt hier hinzustellen
und zu sagen sie hätten nichts damit zu
tun das ist scheinheilig und das ist
unehrlich und ich will Ihnen auch sagen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Ampel wenn Sie hier sagen das sei kein
Gesetz bei dem es spracherhöhung gibt es
gäbe keine Leistungskürzung dann kann
ich Ihnen sagen das stimmt nicht weil
das was sie hier tun ist sie belasten
einseitig die Beitragszahler sie drehen
gute Regelungen zurück sie belasten
Ärztinnen und Ärzte sie belasten
Apotheker sie belasten den Pharma den
Forschungsstandort Deutschland und das
sagen Ihnen alle Akteure und sie stellen
sich hier hin und sagen das ist nicht so
insofern stimmt das nicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und ich will
Ihnen auch genau sagen warum das nicht
stimmt erstens neue patientenregelungen
war eine Regelung die wir in der letzten
Legislatur gemeinsam mit der SPD hier im
Plenum auf den Weg gebracht haben da
geht es darum dass Ärzten und Ärzte
zusätzlich Patienten behandeln können
dafür extra budgetär also zusätzlich
vergütet werden und viele Patientinnen
und Patienten haben dadurch schnell
zeitnah Facharzttermine bekommen und
deshalb haben wir auch gesagt als
Unionsfraktion wir wollen nicht dass
diese Regelung zurückgedreht wird liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn man über dieses Defizit 17
Milliarden spricht also das Problem ist
ja ganz klar benannt wir haben 17
Milliarden Defizit im kommenden Jahr in
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung was
tut man als Gesundheitsminister man
macht zunächst das Offensichtliche und
das Offensichtliche wäre gewesen 10
Milliarden Euro die im System fehlen
weil die Beiträge für ALG2 Bezieher eben
nicht aus Steuermitteln in das
Gesundheitssystem gezahlt werden dass
man sich erstmal darum kümmert lieber
Herr Kollege Lauterbach und das haben
sie nicht getan sondern sie sagen sie
finden keine Einigung mit dem
Bundesfinanzminister mit Herrn Lindner
also lassen Sie es und machen es über
angeblich Effizienz Reserven im System
und das wird nicht funktionieren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich darf ich darf Ihnen auch noch
mal vielleicht eine Anregung mitgeben
Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister wenn man das
Offensichtliche schon nicht tun möchte
und sagt man will andere Lösungen auf
den Weg bringen dann höre ich doch auch
mal den Akteuren zu und dann frage ich
mich doch auch mal warum ist es so dass
beispielsweise die Ärztinnen Ärzte sagen
das wird so nicht funktionieren sie
müssen Kapazitäten abbauen Patientinnen
und Patienten werden schlechter versorgt
werden Apotheken werden in der Fläche in
Schieflage bekommen die flächendeckende
Versorgung wird auf der Kippe stehen und
jetzt hier zu sagen das sei ein
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz kann ich
Ihnen sagen das ist kein
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz es ist ein
Problem für schiebegesetz und das müssen
sie zur Kenntnis nehmen die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und der absolute Gipfel ist in dieser
Diskussion wenn man dann sagt man will
als Gesundheitsminister überhaupt nicht
die Debatte mit dem Bundesfinanzminister
führen man übernimmt und ein unternimmt
überhaupt nicht den Versuch zu sagen
lieber Bundesfinanzminister diese 10
Milliarden müssen doch ins System rein
dann sagen sie einfach naja sie müssen
eventuell mal mit Christian Lindner
sprechen aber offenkundig hat man ja den
Eindruck dass Herr Lindner immer andere
Dinge versteht als sie verstehen und sie
keine Einigung finden und dass sie dann
als Hauptthema vor zwei Tagen in die
Debatte einbringt die Legalisierung des
Kiffens da kann ich nur sagen das sind
die Prioritäten völlig verschoben
innerhalb der andere Regierung liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen also machen Sie
Ihre Arbeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel hören sie auf zur
jammern regieren sie regieren heißt
nicht jammern regieren heißt machen
machen sie endlich die Kliniken die
Akteuren Gesundheitswesen hatten darauf
vielen Dank
Tino Sorge fordert hier eine andere
Prioritätensetzung unter anderem wenn es
um die Legalisierung von Cannabis geht
für die hatten sich ja auch die Grünen
sehr stark gemacht für die Grünen
Fraktion spricht jetzt Maria klein
schmeint die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident meine lieben Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hier im Raum Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
warum reden wir über dieses
Stabilitätsgesetz warum müssen wir
darüber reden wir müssen darüber reden
weil wir ein Defizit von 17 Milliarden
Euro aus der letzten Wahlperiode geerbt
haben Ex Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn
hat viel Geld ausgegeben viel Geld
ausgegeben aber keinerlei Vorsorge
getroffen dafür wie wir eine stabile
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen Aufgaben
hinbekommen das müssen wir mal als
erstes festhalten
und ganz klar muss man sagen eine
stabile Finanzierung ist das Rückgrat
für ein funktionierendes
Gesundheitssystem
und da stellen Sie sich hier hin Herr
Sorge und reden davon es ginge um
problemverschiebung ich würde mal sagen
die Weltmeister im Problem verschieben
im Gesundheitsbereich war die
unionsgeführten Regierungszeiten
wir haben ja nicht nur das Verschieben
des Problems der Finanzierung sondern
wir haben auch die wesentlichen
Strukturreform nicht vorgefunden die
gehen wir jetzt an da sind wir mit
volldruck dabei sowohl im Bereich der
Krankenhausfinanzierung in der
Krankenhausplanung insgesamt in der
versorgungstruktur das gehen wir an und
wir gehen den Fachkräftemangel an
und in diesem so schwierigen Zeiten
stellen wir uns auch den
Herausforderungen denn jetzt für 2023
eine sichere stabile Finanzierung
hinzukriegen und ja das haben ja auch
viele der Beiträge in der Anhörung
gezeigt da sind auch Zumutungen dabei da
sind die Zumutungen dabei dass die
Versicherten mehr bezahlen müssen
insgesamt Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer
0,3 Prozentpunkte
0,15 also für die Versicherten aber wir
haben eben auch Zumutungen sowohl für
die Pharmaindustrie für die Apotheken
auch für die Ärzteschaft aber diese
Zumutung sind vertretbar denn wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir erstens die
Stabilität hinbekommen wir müssen dahin
hinbekommen dass wir nicht einen
riesigen beitragssprung haben und genau
das haben wir mit vereinten Kräften
geschaffen und zwar so dass wir das gut
vertreten können weil wir die Auswirkung
auf die verschiedenen Bereiche sehr gut
abgewogen haben und geschaut haben dass
wir da nicht zu spitzen kommen und wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass es eine
Evaluierung gibt und diese Evaluierung
wird dafür sorgen dass wir nachsteuern
können und dort dafür sorgen können dass
dann Probleme die sich auch die
auftreten dann beseitigt werden können
ich will zum Schluss noch mal sagen die
Aufgabe bleibt dass wir für 2024
folgende eine gerechte stabile
finanzierung auch mit Steuermitteln
hinbekommen diese Aufgabe müssen sich
alle hier im Hause stellen es wird um
Milliardenbeträge gehen aber auch das
werden wir schaffen
[Applaus]
optimistisch Maria klein schmeink von
Bündnis 90 den Grünen im Bundestag
nächster Redner ist Martin sichert der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
vor elf Jahren stand der Papst an dieser
Stelle er zitierte den heiligen
Augustinus mit dem Worten nimm das Recht
weg was ist dann ein Staat noch anderes
als eine große Räuberbande sie haben das
offensichtlich nicht als Warnung sondern
als Anleitung verstanden sie verhalten
sich nicht wie eine verantwortungsvolle
Regierung sondern wie eine Räuberbande
die das Land plündert und verwüstet wie
auch das vorliegende Gesetz zeigt die
Menschen werden ausgenommen bis aufs
letzte Hemd in kaum einem anderen Land
müssen die Bürger so viel von ihrem hart
erarbeiteten Geld an den Staat abdrücken
und mit diesem Gesetz wollen sie den
Menschen doch mehr Abpressen indem die
Krankenkassenbeiträge auf Rekordniveau
steigen wir sind schon Weltmeister bei
steuern und Energiekosten und sie
erhöhen die Belastung immer weiter
einige von ihnen planen sogar den
sogenannten Lastenausgleich also die
staatliche Enteignung von Millionen
Eigenheimbesitzern sie verw wir müssen
das Land sie machen nicht nur mit ihrer
Energiepolitik das Land zur
industriellen Wüste und mit ihrer
Toleranz gegenüber Sexualverbrechern und
Clans das Land zur
sicherheitspolitischen Wüste sondern
auch mit lauterbachspolitik zur
gesundheitspolitischen Wüste die
Auswirkungen davon sehen wir bereits
eine Übersterblichkeit insbesondere in
den jungen Altersgruppen zeugt vom
Niedergang des Gesundheitssystems sie
beschäftigen sich noch nicht einmal
damit es könnte ja möglicherweise etwas
mit der Impfung zu tun haben stattdessen
versetzt die Bundesregierung dem
Gesundheitswesen einen Schlag nach dem
anderen Krankenkassen die solide
gewirtschaftet haben werden die
Rücklagen per Gesetz abgebrannt Pflegern
wird erzählt Nachtschichten werden
überflüssig Apotheken die eh schon mit
Energiekosten Inflation und steigenden
Personalkosten zu kämpfen haben wie in
kürzen Sie auch noch das Honorar und
versetzen damit etlichen Apotheken den
Todesstoß
während die Menschen aufgefordert werden
zwei Pullover anzuziehen sich nur mit
Waschlappen zu waschen und in die Dusche
zu pinkeln baut man dem Kanzler einen
prunkpalast für 777 Millionen Euro geht
es noch
ich möchte dass diese Politik auf Kosten
der Bürger ein Ende hat deswegen machen
wir von der AFD mehr konstruktive
Vorschläge als jede andere Fraktion
allein zu diesem Tagesordnungspunkt
liegen fünf Anträge zur Abstimmung vor
die AFD will die Anwendung von medizinal
Cannabis erleichtern sie alle sagen nein
warum Schmerzpatienten helfen solange es
nicht um den kipperspaß geht ist ihnen
Cannabis völlig egal die AFD will die
Budgetierung der Ärzte aufheben sie alle
sagen nein warum etwas dafür tun um die
unerträglich langen Wartezeiten von
Kassenpatienten bei Fachärztin zu
reduzieren schließlich sind die meisten
Bundestagsabgeordneten ja privat
versichert und damit nicht betroffen die
AFD will als nein ich bin gesetzlich
versichert wenn sie schon fragen Frau
Kollegin die AFD will
Arzneimittelsicherheit verbessern und
sie alle sagen nein warum sollen wir
denn die Gesundheit der Bürger schützen
schließlich empfangen die
Pharma-Lobbyisten Bundestagsabgeordnete
vielfreundlicher wenn Medikamente wie
die corona-impfung vor der
millionenfachen anwend dann Mäusen
getestet werden
hören Sie endlich auf sich wie eine
Räuberbande zu verhalten und nehmen Sie
so wie wir die Verantwortung gegenüber
83 Millionen Mitbürgern Ernst treten sie
ihren fatalen Gesetzesentwurf in die
Tonne und nehmen Sie unsere Anträge zum
Wohl der Menschen an vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Sicherheit
[Applaus]
nächste Redner ist der Kollege Professor
andre Ullmann FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte herr Präsident meine Damen
und Herren die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung liegt auf der
Intensivstation weil notwendige
Therapien in der Vergangenheit versäumt
wurden eine katastrophale Folge von acht
Jahren verfehlter Gesundheitspolitik der
Union
ohne
ohne einen Gesetzentwurf wie diesen will
die wurde der Zusatzbeitrag um
mindestens einen Prozentpunkt steigen
dies würde eine Mehrbelastung von
mehrere hundert Euro für den Mittelstand
in diesem Land nach sich ziehen so eine
Beitragssteigerung würde die
entlassungspakete zu Inflation und
Energiepreisen zum Teil wirkungslos
machen hier übernimmt die Ampel
Verantwortung da ist es wichtig dass wir
dieses Gesetz heute verabschieden
im parlamentarischen Verfahren haben wir
wesentliche Änderungen zum Gesetz
erreichen können dieses
Gesetzgebungsverfahren hat wieder einmal
gezeigt dass das
parlamentarischverfahren ein echten
Mehrwert bringt deshalb mein Dank an die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der SPD Bundes
90 die Grünen und an das BMG für die
konstruktive Diskussion und Vorschlägen
die Streichung der neupatientenregelung
bleibt zwar bestehen jedoch verbessern
wir die Vergütung der Fach- und
Hausärzte bei der Vermittlung über die
terminservicestellen und bei überweisen
durch die v-hausärzte dies ist eine ganz
wichtige Initiative damit faire Anreize
gesetzt werden die Versorgung von
Patientinnen und Patienten ohne festen
Arzt auch weiterhin in einer hohen
Qualität zu sicherzustellen
auch im Arzneimittelbereich sind
wesentliche Änderungen am Gesetz
erreicht worden die erstattungsschwelle
für Arzneimittel gegen seltene
Erkrankungen wird nun auf 30 Billionen
statt auf 20 Millionen Euro abgesenkt in
der Anhörung zum Gesetz haben
insbesondere patientenvertreterinnen und
Vertreter auf die Bedeutung dieser Regel
und dieser Arzneimittel hingewiesen wir
haben gut zugehört und haben eine neue
Lösung gemeinsam geschaffen
zudem schaffen wir ein
ausnahmeberegelung beim fixen
kombinationsabschlag wir ermöglichen
durch einen entsprechenden
nutzungsnachweis die Aussetzung des
Abschlags dies ist ein wichtiger
Anpassung zum Wohle der Patientinnen und
Patientin und das pharmazeutischen
Fortschritts damit auch Innovationen
weiterhin beim Patienten ankommen
meine Damen
meine Damen und meine Herren dieses
Gesetz dient uns als Brücke größere
Strukturreformen müssen gemeinsam
angegangen werden damit schreiben wir
Strukturreformen fest und erweitern
diesen Auftrag und Bürokratieabbau und
Transparenz bei den Krankenkassen ein
längst überfälliger Schritt das Gesetz
ist immer noch ein
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz es macht
keine Freude so ein Gesetz zu erarbeiten
oder beschließen zu müssen wir müssen
besser weitermachen denn sollten wir
zukünftig nichts ändern scheitern auch
wir es liegt nun an uns die
fortschrittskoalition mutig die
notwendigen Strukturreformen anzugehen
hier sehen wir bereit denn wir wollen
dass die medizinische Versorgung
digitaler innovativer und nachhaltiger
wird so wird das Gesundheitssystem
resilienter auf viele zukünftige
Herausforderungen wie zum Beispiel der
demografische Wandel
wir wollen dass alle im Gesundheitswesen
Tätigen wieder zufrieden sind mit ihren
Tätigkeiten egal ob im Pflegeheim im
Krankenhaus in der Apotheke oder in der
Praxis
wir wollen Deutschland wieder lukrativer
machen für die Ansiedlung von
biotechnologischen und pharmazeutischen
Unternehmen ein nach das ist nämlich
eine nachhaltige Industrie das meine
Damen und Herren sind unsere Aufgaben
und ich lade auch die Verantwortlichen
den Landesparlamenten hier ausdrücklich
ein hier konstruktiv mitzuarbeiten
zum Ende
zum Ende meiner Rede möchte ich noch auf
einen Punkt Hinweisen wir Freie
Demokraten waren in der letzten
Legislaturperiode als
Oppositionsfraktion im Hohen Haus aktiv
wir haben diese Rolle sehr ernst
genommen jeder Eintrag unsererseits war
gegen finanziert und durch bestehende
Haushaltsmittel gedeckt das ist
arbeitsintensiv es ist aber auch
Bestandteil des Jobs von der AFD und von
den Linken erwarte ich keine solide
Arbeit aber von der Union jedoch schon
daher hat es mich entsetzt dass sie im
Ausschuss Änderungsanträge gestellt
haben die ungedeckte Mehrausgaben von
1,5 Milliarden Euro enthielten sie geben
leere Versprechungen ab nehmen weiterer
Steigerung für den deutschen Mittelstand
in kauf sie wissen selbst dass das keine
gute Oppositionsarbeit ist aber zum
Glück haben sie noch mindestens sieben
Jahre weitere Zeit zu üben herzlichen
Dank
soweit der gesundheitspolitische
Sprecher der Liberalen Hirten Deutschen
Bundestag andre Ullmann und für die
Linksfraktion wird nun die Sprecherin
für Gesundheitspolitik sprechen das ist
Katrin Vogler schon auf dem Weg zum
Rednerpult
[Applaus]
ja vielen Dank herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen leider haben
SPD und Grüne in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen ihre Versprechen
aus dem Wahlkampf für eine gerechtere
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung aufgegeben dabei
wäre gerade das jetzt die Antwort auf
die gigantischen Herausforderungen für
unser Gesundheitswesen und das von Ihnen
Herr Lauterbach hier vorgelegte
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetz hat
seinen Namen nicht ansatzweise verdient
ehrlicherweise sollte es GKV
finanzierungs-mog-gesetz heißen denn ihr
Defizit sollten die Krankenkassen
größtenteils selbst stopfen indem sie
Rücklagen verbrauchen also Gelder die
von den Versicherten eingezahlt wurden
zudem erhalten Sie ein zwangsweises
Darlehen aus der Staatskasse von dem
niemand weiß wann und wovon das
zurückgezahlt werden soll und dann
werden noch die Zusatzbeiträge erhöht
das belastet doch gerade die Menschen
die im Moment sowieso kaum wissen wie
sie ihre Rechnungen für Energie und
Essen bezahlen sollen und dabei stimmen
schon die Berechnungsgrundlagen nicht
alle seriösen Schätzungen gehen davon
aus dass wegen der energiepreiskrise
wegen Inflation und Rezession das
Defizit im nächsten Jahr schon sehr viel
höher ausfallen wird und bei vielen
ihrer Sparmaßnahmen ist völlig unklar ob
sie am Ende überhaupt genug Geld
einbringen oder nicht doch zusätzliche
Kosten verursachen also was sie hier
vorgelegt haben Herr Lauterbach das ist
nicht nur ungerecht sondern auch
unausgegoren
und
lieber Andrew Ullmann weil wir ja eine
konstruktive und seriöse Opposition sind
schlägt Ihnen die Linke heute eine
gerechte und nachhaltige Lösung vor wenn
wir nämlich die
Versicherungspflichtgrenze und die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze in der
Krankenversicherung auf das Niveau der
Rentenversicherung anheben und damit
mehr Beiträge eine nehmen brauchen die
Beiträge für Menschen mit niedrigem und
mittlerem Einkommen nicht zu steigen wir
schlagen darüber hinaus vor die Beiträge
die der Bund für ALG2 beziehende Zahl zu
erhöhen und effektiver gegen Mondpreise
für neue Arzneimittel vorzugehen und
allein die Absenkung der Mehrwertsteuer
auf Arzneimittel die wir vorschlagen die
würde fünf Milliarden Euro etwa
einbringen genauso viel wie die Erhöhung
des Zusatzbeitrages nach Ihren Plänen
bringen soll und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von SPD und Grünen Herr
Minister Lauterbach ich verstehe ehrlich
gesagt immer weniger wo wenn wir
überhaupt noch ein
Gesundheitsministerium brauchen wenn am
Ende eh der Finanzminister die
Richtlinien vorgibt und weil das so ist
kommen sie auch in einem anderen Bereich
nicht ausreichend voran nämlich bei der
Entlastung von Krankenhäusern
Pflegeeinrichtungen und pflegenden
Angehörigen von den Kosten für Inflation
und energiepreiskrise deshalb fordern
wir in einem Entschließungsantrag den
wir gleich namentlich abstimmen lassen
ein
energiekostenentlastungspaket für
defizitäre akut und Rehakliniken eine
Deckelung der Eigenanteile für Menschen
in pflegeanrichteinrichtungen und ein
Inflationsausgleich beim Pflegegeld denn
im Menschen und den Einrichtungen steht
das Wasser bis zum Hals Herr Lauterbach
handeln sie endlich
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Vogler
die Opposition hat hier auch mehrere
Anträge eingebracht unter anderem hat
die Linksfraktion einen
Entschließungsantrag auch hier zu dem
Gesetzentwurf eingebracht über den die
Abgeordneten namentlich abstimmen nach
dieser Debatte
genau vor einer Woche hat der beim
Bundesamt für soziale Sicherung
angesiedelte Schätzerkreis eine Prognose
für die Entwicklung der Einnahmen und
Ausgaben der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung oder Krankenkassen
im kommenden Jahr vorgenommen und dabei
das historisch hohe Defizit von 17
Milliarden Euro bestätigt eine
bedrückende Erkenntnis aber keine
Überraschung wir wissen alle dass seit
Jahren die Ausgaben mit jährlich rund
vier Prozentpunkten spürbar stärker als
der Einnahmen wachsen es herrscht also
kein erkenntnisdefizit wir wissen
schließlich das fehlende
Strukturreformen sowie populäre
allerdings teure leistungsreformen
dieses Defizit von 17 Milliarden Euro zu
verantworten haben und das war alles
unter Minister Spahn
mit diesem hier in der zweiten und
dritten Lesung vorliegenden
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetz müssen
wir genau dieses Defizit kurzfristig ich
betone kurzfristig schließen dabei steht
für meine Fraktion fest dass die Lasten
auf mehrere Schultern verteilt werden
müssen was sich in einem höheren
Bundeszuschuss und der Heranziehung von
Finanzreserven der Kassen und des
Gesundheitsfonds widerspiegelt aber auch
des Beitrages seitens der
Pharmaindustrie ernst:innen
Zahnärztinnen Apothekerinnen und
Krankenhäuser denn ohne diese
Lastenverteilung müsste das Defizit
ausschließlich von beitragszahlerinnen
und Beitragszahlern durch einen
Zusatzbeitrag Herr Kollege Ullmann hat
es gesagt von bis zu 1% geschultert
werden dennoch wird es nicht ohne
Beitragssteigerung gehen im Durchschnitt
werden die Beitragssätze um 0,3
Prozentpunkte moderat steigen
im Rahmen des parlamentarischen
Verfahrens haben wir getreu dem
druckschen Gesetz wo nicht passiert wo
kein Gesetz das Parlament passiert so
wie es eingebracht worden ist Änderung
vorgenommen wir haben und da gebe ich
auch meinem Kollegen Ullmann vollkommen
Recht unter Beweis gestellt dass in
Zeiten wo eine Krise die nächste Jagd
der Parlamentarismus dessen Wesen der
Kompromiss ist funktioniert und das
findet sich hier in den 17
Änderungsanträgen in unterschiedlichen
Bereichen seine Niederschlag wobei wir
eine ganze Reihe wichtiger Verbesserung
gegenüber dem Ursprungsentwurf erreicht
haben so konnte das Schonvermögen für
kleine Kassen von zwei auf vier
Millionen Euro erhöht werden und die
Bezahlung der Parodontitis-Behandlung
für Pflegebedürftige und Menschen mit
Behinderung verbessert werden bei den
Arzneimitteln haben wir den Kern der
Reform verteidigt und unter anderem noch
Verbesserungen für Kombinationstherapien
und bei Arzneimitteln gegen seltene
Erkrankungen sowie die opt-in-regelung
erreicht all diese Maßnahmen werden
kritisch evaluiert und begleitet
dadurch sichern wir den Forschungs- und
Produktionsstandort hier in Deutschland
wichtig für uns
Koalition sind uns auch getreu unserem
Koalitionsvertrag die Schwerpunktthemen
Bürokratieabbau und Transparenz
schließlich wollen wir das Personal des
Gesundheitswesen und im Gesundheitswesen
entlasten und wir wollen Verbesserungen
im Bereich der Service und
Versorgungsqualität für die Patientinnen
und Patienten erreichen hierfür soll das
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit
Empfehlungen bis zum 30.09 des kommenden
Jahres vorlegen bei der Ärzte
Honorierung werden wir den Wegfall der
neupatientenregelung durch verbesserte
Zuschläge für eine schnelle
terphin-terminvergabe kompensieren das
soll die Rolle der Hausärzte und auch
die terminservicestellen Stärken und ist
ein bedeutender Schritt gegen die zwei
klassenmedizin
auch diese Maßnahme wird in regelmäßigen
Abständen evaluiert und kritisch
begleitet an dieser Stelle darf ich mich
bei den Berichterstattern Andrew Ulmen
als auch kleinschmark nochmals herzlich
bedanken für die konstruktive Beratung
denn trotz manchmal unterschiedlicher
Sichtweisen haben wir konstruktiv an
einem gemeinsamen Ziel gearbeitet
nämlich die Liquiditätssicherung und
Stabilisierung der GKV für das kommende
Jahr und das ist uns in dem vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf gelungen wie ich eingangs
schon gesagt habe das wachsende
strukturelle Defizit in der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung ist eine Folge von
versäumten Strukturen sowie populären
Strukturreformen sowie populären
allerdings teuren leistungsreformen und
der Minister Spahn mit diesem Gesetz
bringen wir jetzt
beginnen wir jetzt und machen
weitreichende Strukturreformen bei der
Arzneimittelversorgung aber auch weitere
Strukturreformen im Gesundheitswesen
werden folgen insbesondere im
Krankenhausbereich denn die sind bereits
schon in Arbeit unabhängig davon habe
ich für meine für meine Fraktion eine
klare Erwartungshaltung dass wir die
grundsätzlichen Finanzierungsfragen
angehen müssen um das strukturelle
Defizit nicht nur kurzfristig sondern
auch nachhaltig zu beseitigen für meine
Fraktion möchte ich daher Unfalls
verständlich betonen dass wir uns an den
Leitplanken des Koalitionsvertrages
dabei orientieren werden das schließt
ausdrücklich die regelhafte
Dynamisierung des Bundeszuschusses sowie
höhere Beiträge für die Beziehung
Bezieher von Arbeitslosengeld II aus
Steuermitteln mit ein
in diesem Sinne freue ich mich auf die
kommenden Monate und Jahre in denen die
fortschrittskoalition diese
Strukturreform im Gesundheitsbereich die
über Jahre liegen geblieben sind angehen
wird oder wie wir in niedersächsischen
sagen würden wir werden anpacken und
besser machen herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank
pantazis war das für die SPD-Fraktion
damit kommen wir zum nächsten Redner
Stefan pilsinger
Sprecher für Gesundheit der CSU
Landesgruppe
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
der redet doch nur über Corona das nervt
langsam echt das sagen die Menschen in
Deutschland wenn Sie über unseren
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
sprechen Herr Lauterbach wenn sie mal
nicht über Corona sprechen dann erzählen
sie uns dauernd welches Thema Sie als
nächstes anpacken wollen und was
passiert dann nichts einfach nichts Karl
Lauterbach ist ein reiner
ankündigungsminister und nicht mehr
ihre Untätigkeit zur Lösung wirklich
wichtiger Probleme in unserem
Gesundheitssystem halte langsam ich fast
nicht mehr aus die Ampel hat sich ja
richtigerweise zum Ziel gesetzt die
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen nachhaltig zu reformieren
und was tun sie jetzt nichts davon was
sie sich im Koalitionsvertrag mal
vorgenommen haben das ist doch völlig
abstrus
stattdessen
legen Sie uns heute das
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetz vor das
faktisch ein Gesundheitssystem
destabilisierungsgesetz ist dieses
Gesetz ist reine Flickschusterei zum
Stopfen vom finanzlöchern ohne einen
nachhaltigen Effekt Herr
Gesundheitsminister
sie haben einen mehrfach angekündigt
dass es zu keinen Leistungskürzungen bei
dem Versicherten kommen soll sie nennen
Leistungskürzung deshalb jetzt einfach
das Heben von Effizienzen und Reserven
vor wenigen Monaten haben sie noch den
Beschäftigten im Gesundheitssystem ihre
in der Tat für ihre in der Tat
herausragenden Leistung zu Bewältigung
der corona-krise gedankt jetzt kürzen
Sie bei den Zahnärzten den Fachärzten
bei den Apothekern und den
arzneimittelnherstellern das ist für Sie
also das Heben von Effizienzreserven
eine absolute Frechheit her
Gesundheitsminister ist das
ich kann Ihnen heute schon sagen zu was
ihre kurzsichtigen Einsparung am Ende
führen werden ihre Kürzungen bei dem
zahnmedizinischen Prävention und hier
insbesondere bei der hochwirksamen
paradontitis-behandlung wird die
Zahngesundheit der Menschen in
Deutschland dauerhaft gefährden ihre
massive Reduktion der
neupatientenpauschale wird für
Kassenpatienten zu einer massiven
Verlängerung erwartezeiten auf ein
Facharzttermin führen ihre Einsparung
beim packungsabschlag werden das
apothekensterben vor allem im ländlichen
raumbeschleunigen und damit die
Arzneimittelversorgung der Patienten
verschlechtern dass sie die
pharmazeutische Industrie auf diese Art
und Weise unangemessen Schröpfen wird
viele Arbeitsplätze kosten und dazu
führen dass innovative Arzneimittel in
Deutschland nicht mehr verfügbar sein
werden das Schlimmste aber ist der
Gesundheitsminister dass ihre Einsparung
am Ende die Gesundheit der Patienten in
Deutschland verschlechtern werden und
damit langfristig Mehrkosten auslösen
werden als sie jetzt mit dem Gesetz
einsparen können deshalb lehnt die
Unionsfraktion Grundgesetz auch mit
voller Überzeugung vielen Dank
vielen dank Stefan pilsinger nannte hier
den Gesetzentwurf eine Frechheit
erarbeitet neben seiner
Abgeordnetentätigkeit übrigens auch als
Hausarzt noch und damit kommen wir zur
Paula piechotta für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen sie sitzt im Haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und vor allem
auch liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf
der Tribüne die wir ja sie und wir alle
auch Patientinnen diesen
Gesundheitswesen sind ich war vor ein
paar Wochen bei meinem Schwager zu Gast
der hat seinen 40 Geburtstag
nachgefeiert und der ist
niedergelassener Kinderarzt in
Baden-Württemberg und ich war kaum zur
Tür rein da wurde ich gefragt bist du
auch für dieses Spargesetz wenn ja
kannst du dein Essen heute Mittag selber
bezahlen
und dann habe ich erklärt dass ich
dadurch aus dafür bin dass ich verstehe
dass viele Menschen so wie er im
Gesundheitswesen jetzt nicht in
begeisterungsstämme verfallen wenn
dieses Gesetz verkündet wird das ist
auch definitiv nicht alle Probleme im
Gesundheitswesen jetzt schon löst die
wir ja mit dem Koalitionsvertrag ganz
richtigerweise angehen wollen und das
natürlich auch niemand behauptet dass
wir damit die Finanzierungsprobleme in
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung ab
2024 lösen aber trotzdem ist dieses
Gesetz notwendig weil es die
Finanzierung der Gesundheitsversorgung
von Millionen von Menschen nämlich den
90 Prozent den der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung versichert sind und
damit nicht zu den höchstverdienerinnen
gehören weil es deren
Gesundheitsversorgung für 2023 absichert
[Applaus]
denn wir absurd wäre das in der Zeit wo
wir gerade die Menschen mit mittleren
und niedrigen Einkommen angesichts von
steigenden Energiepreisen angesichts von
hoher Inflation entlassen wollen wenn
gleichzeitig genau für diese Menschen
die
gesundheitskassenbeiträge weiter
ansteigen würden als das was wir jetzt
in sehr engem Umfang tun und deswegen
ist das eben den Gesetz was die Lasten
im Gesundheitswesen verteilt die Lasten
der Finanzierung der GKV auf die
Kliniken auf die Kassen auf die
Apothekerinnen und Apotheker auf die
niedergelassenen Ärztinnen auf die
Versicherten aber eben auch weil das
jetzt vielfach angesprochen wurde eben
auch auf den Bundeshaushalt wir geben
auch als Parlamentarier die im
Haushaltsausschuss sitzen eben nicht nur
den normalen normalen Bundeszuschuss von
14,5 Milliarden sondern der
Bundeszuschuss wird aufgestockt und es
gibt zusätzlich noch das Darlehen an der
GKV und obwohl die Ergebnisse des
Schätzerkreises ein bisschen besser
waren als erwartet wurde das nicht
abgeschmolzen das ist auch der Beitrag
der Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
in diesem für die Finanzierung der GKV
im nächsten Jahr und das habe ich alles
meinem Schwager erklärt am Ende durfte
ich mitessen ohne selber zu bezahlen
aber natürlich natürlich ist es auch so
dass das alles nur funktioniert wenn wir
jetzt nach Verabschiedung dieses
Gesetzes auch die Finanzierung der GKV
für die Jahre 2024 folgende angehen und
ich fand es spannend was Sepp Müller
neulich vorgeschlagen hat nämlich kaum
in der Opposition hat die CDU sich jetzt
auch bei dem Thema bewegt und hat gesagt
ja wir müssen hier über neue
Finanzierungswege nachdenken und die
Lösung kann nicht immer nur sein mehr
Steuergeld Liebe Union da hat Sepp
Müller Recht und wenn sie sich nicht mal
in der Opposition auf einen Vorschlag
einigen können Sepp Müller musste den ja
zurückziehen und wenn ich im
Haushaltsausschuss keinen einzigen
Antrag von der Union gesehen habe wie
das finanziert werden sollen was sie
jetzt als Lösung vorgeschlagen haben
dann haben wir glaube ich gemeinsam noch
einen langen Weg zu gehen bis wir die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung auch für
2024 auch gute Füße stellen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
und damit kommen wir zum letzten Redner
bevor hier die Abgeordneten über diesen
Gesetzentwurf aus dem Haus von Karl
Lauterbach abstimmen das ist Sepp Müller
der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion herr Präsident meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
wollen ja mit etwas gutem Anfang und das
Gute ist dass die gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung endlich ein Gesetz
vorgelegt bekommen haben und dass sie
nicht nur von Ankündigung leben müssen
das Gute ist auch liebe Ampel dass sie
liebe Kollegen sich bei einigen Dingen
auf den Weg gemacht haben die wir vorher
kritisiert haben
nach 20 Sekunden könnte die Redezeit
beendet sein
ihr habt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
vor allem beim Thema
Leistungskürzung zwei Dinge meines
Erachtens nach und unseres Erachtens
nach nicht richtig geregelt das ist das
Thema neue patientenregelung das Thema
neue patientenregelung heißt zukünftig
jeder neue Patient der in den letzten
zwei Jahren kurzfristig einen Termin
bekommen hat weil sein Arzt
zugesetzliche Zeiten auf dem Weg
gebracht haben hat jetzt keine
Möglichkeit das ist die Leistungskürzung
Nummer eins lieber Gesundheitsminister
sie haben eine Leistungskürzung auf den
Weg gebracht und das ist die
neupatientenregelung das zweite Thema
und das ist wesentlich das ist viel
wesentlicher weil es Menschen trifft
mit seltenen Erkrankungen weil es
Menschen trifft die in unserer
Gesellschaft nicht die Mehrheitsmeinung
sind weil das Menschen trifft mit
Mukoviszidose weil es Menschen trifft
mit MS weil es Menschen treffen mit
mecfs mit seltenerkrankungen dort haben
sie eine Regelung im Gesetz auf den Weg
gebracht die vorsieht dass eine
finanzielle Schwelle deutlich abgesenkt
wird trotz aller Kritik von der
Medizinindustrie diese Schwelle
anzuheben haben Sie nicht darauf
reagiert
das das ist gut dass sie das Sagen
darauf habe ich gewartet Herr Kollege
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage bevor
sie jetzt Antworten auf das was Sie
erwartet haben in der Zwischenfrage ist
die Grünen sehr gerne
die Uhr wird eingehalten der Kollege
Müller haben sie zur Kenntnis genommen
dass es 17 Änderungsanträge im
parlamentarischen Verfahren gegeben
haben und einige der Punkte die sie
gerade angemarkert haben verändert
worden sind unter anderem die orphan
drugs-regelung sie haben sie gerade
angesprochen da haben wir eine
Veränderung vorgenommen und die Schwelle
wieder deutlich angehoben erstens
zweitens haben wir gerade wegen dem msms
msd-präparat haben wir eine Veränderung
vorgenommen auch da ganz ganz deutlich
sind wir auf die verschiedenen
Anmerkungen aus der
Sachverständigen Anhörung eingegangen
weiterhin haben wir an verschiedensten
Stellen abmilderungen gemacht
beispielsweise bei der Belastung der
Ärzteschaft wir haben ein neues System
wir haben nicht mehr einen
neupatientenregelung die nachweislich
nicht zu neuen Fällen und neuen
Beratungs- und Behandlungszeiten geführt
haben im Kern sondern wir haben eine
Regelung die belohnt wenn Ärzte sich
erstens für terminvermittlung einsetzen
zweitens zusätzliche Termine auch
tatsächlich einrichten haben sie das zur
Kenntnis genommen dann könnten sie
eigentlich diesen Teil den sie dort
gerade unterstellt haben nicht weiter so
aufrecht erhalten
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin es gibt mir
noch mal die Möglichkeit darauf
hinzuweisen dass eine verfaulte Banane
wenn sie sie neu einpacken immer noch
verfault bleibt sie sind von 50
Millionen Euro Regelung auf 30 Millionen
Euro runtergegangen das bedeutet für
Menschen mit seltenen Erkrankungen deren
Anteil an der Herr tablettenproduktion
deutlich geringer ist dass die Industrie
und da war der Einwurf vollkommen
richtig in der Expertenanhörung dass die
Industrie sagt das wird sich finanziell
nicht mehr lohnen können lasst es bei 50
Millionen Euro in den letzten Jahren
sind zahlreiche und das wissen sie Frau
Kollegin in den letzten Jahren sind
zahlreiche Medikamente für Menschen mit
seltenerkrankungen auf dem Weg gebracht
wurden weil wir gemeinsam mit der
Sozialdemokratie die Schwelle auf 50
Millionen Euro hochgenommen haben und
was machen jetzt grüne was mache ich
jetzt FDP sie senken die Schwelle sie
zeigen die rote Karte für Menschen mit
Erkrankung und das finde ich sehr
bedauerlich
und
neben ihren 17 Änderungsanträgen wo sie
vieles auf der Hälfte haben stehen
lassen liegt ja heute auch eine
Ergänzungsantrag von uns vor setzen Sie
Ihren
Koalitionsvertrag um mir stimmen wir
liegen ihnen dir vor lassen sie in die
Arbeitslosengeld 2 Empfänger eins zu
eins beteiligen warum das geht um 10
Milliarden Euro und das warum möchte ich
noch erklären zehn Milliarden Euro bei
den Riesen wummspaketen die sie
raushauen sind ja dann fast schon
Peanuts aber was bedeutet das im
Umkehrschluss
für einen GKV-Patienten zahlt das
Jobcenter im Arbeitslosengeld II Bezug
110 Euro für einen privat
krankenversichererin Hartz IV Empfänger
zahlt das Jobcenter 380 Euro das ist
nicht gerecht Liebe Sozialdemokratie
hier müsst ihr Nachschärfen und diesen
Antrag legen wir euch Kollege erlauben
sie eine Zwischenfrage noch das Kollegen
Janusz Dame es erhöht natürlich Redezeit
dramatisch sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
aber bereits von den Grünen eine
Zwischenfrage kam würde ich darauf
verzichten weil die Tagesordnung heute
noch sehr lang ist
bedanke mich herzlich bei Ihnen also
wir haben immer noch die Möglichkeit
insolventionen Herr Kollege und neben
diesen Themen ALG2 Empfänger richtig aus
dem Bundeshaushalt auch
volkswirtschaftlich zu betrachten geben
wir Ihnen auch noch andere Themen an die
Hand unter anderem die richtige
Finanzierung unseres Pflegesystems die
richtige Finanzierung der Krankenhäuser
nicht nur ankündigen Herr Minister
machen das ist ihre Aufgabe und da
versagt diese ampelregierung mit diesem
Gesetz deswegen lehnen wir das ab
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Müller
[Applaus]
damit schließe ich die Aussprache
hier noch einen Hinweis zum Ablauf nach
drei einfachen Abstimmungen folgt gleich
einen namentliche Abstimmung daran
schließen sich noch acht weitere
einfache Abstimmungen an die
Abgeordneten hier im Saal bitte ich
dafür noch zu bleiben oder aber falls
eine Fraktion auf die glorreiche die
kommen sollte die Beschlussfähigkeit
oder das vom Friseur festgestellt
abstimmungs 1 zu zweifeln werde ich sie
zum kurz unterbrechen und die Kollegen
Kollegen die draußen Lobby ihrer Pflicht
nachkommen hereinrufen also bitte darum
solche Sachen zu lassen
Zusatzpunkt 4a liegt dafür liegt mir an
Erklärung zur Abschwung gemäß mal auf 31
Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages vor wir kommen nun zur
Abstimmung über den von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur finanziellen
Stabilisierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung der Ausschuss für
Gesundheit empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a
seine Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.86 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksachen 3.448
und 3.713 in der ausschussfassung
anzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
die koalitionsfraktion wer stimmt
dagegen der Rest des Hauses damit ist
der Gesetzentwurf in zweiter Beratung
angenommen dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die wieder zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen und
ein Abgeordneten
gut also die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen
das sind die vielen Fraktionen des
Hauses damit ist
der Gesetzentwurf auch in der dritten
Lesung angenommen so das bedeutet also
das ist Höhe einen höheren
Bundeszuschuss geben wird höhere
Beiträge der Versicherten 16,2% des
Bruttolohns werden die Versicherten der
gesetzlichen Krankenkasse nun zahlen
müssen und es auch Einsparungen geben
wird auf Drucksache 4.093 jetzt kommen
wir zu zwei
Entschließungsanträgen der erste über
den jetzt hier abgestimmt werden soll
ist von der Linksfraktion unter anderem
fordert die Linksfraktion in diesem
Entschließungsantrag ein
Energieeffizienzprogramm für
Krankenhäuser mit einem Gesamtvolumen
von 5 Milliarden Euro im ersten Schritt
und Sie sehen es schon dass hier viele
Abgeordnete raus ein denn die
Linksfraktion hat hier
im namentliche Abstimmung beantragt die
natürlich nicht hier im Plenum
stattfindet sondern draußen in der wirst
Lobby wie seit Beginn der
corona-pandemie eingeübt auch die
cdu/csu hat einen Entschließungsantrag
eingereicht der wurde eben auch schon
allerdings abgelehnt wo sie wie auch
eben in der letzten Rede wie von Sepp
Müller gefordert gefordert hat
Arbeitslosengeld II Empfänger hier zu
beteiligen wenn es darum geht die
Finanzen der Krankenhäuser zu verbessern
oder Buchstabe c empfiehlt der Ausschuss
die Ablehnung des Antrags der Fraktion
der AFD auf Drucksache 2.360 mit dem
Titel Abschaffung der Budgetierung für
Ärzte wer bestimmt für diese Empfehlung
ja stimmt dagegen dann ist gegen die
Stimmen der afd-fraktion diese
schussempfehlung mit den Stimmen der
übrigen Fraktion des Hauses angenommen
weiterhin empfiehlt der Ausschuss unter
Buchstabe d seiner Beschlussempfehlung
die Ablehnung des Antrags der Fraktion
der AFD auf Drucksache 3.532 mit dem
Titel Bevorzugung von den
port-nationalen mit den beenden
Arzneimittelsicherheit verbessern wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
wer stimmt dagegen da ist diese schöne
Empfehlung gegen die Stimmen der
afd-fraktion mit Stimmen Fraktionen des
Hauses angenommen unter Buchstabe e
empfiehlt der Ausschuss die Ablehnung
des Antrags der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache 3533 mit dem Titel
Lieferengpässe bei Arzneimitteln
wirksame Grenzen Abhängigkeit der
Arzneimittelversorgung von
Nicht-EU-Ausland abbauen wer stimmt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung ja stimmt
dagegen dann ist diese
Beschlussempfehlung gegen die Stimmen
der afd-fraktion mit den Stimmen der
überfraktion des Hauses angenommen des
Weiteren empfiehlt der Ausschuss in der
Buchstabe F seiner Beschlussempfehlung
die Ablehnung des Antrags der Fraktion
der AFD auf Drucksache 3.536 mit dem
Titel Abschaffung des dag Systems im
Krankenhaus und Einführung des
prospektivregionalen pauschalsystems wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
ja stimmt dagegen Enthaltungen keine ist
diese beschussempfehlung gegen die
Stimmen der afd-fraktion mit dem
Fraktion des Hauses angenommen
unter Buchstabe g empfiehlt der
Ausschuss die Ablehnung des Antrags der
Fraktion der AFD auf Drucksache 3.537
mit dem Titel Verfahren der
Nutzenbewertung und Preisfindung im
Arzneimittelmarkt neuordnungsgesetz auch
auf Medizin keine medizinal Cannabis
anwenden und damit gleichzeitig die
Anwendungssicherheit verbessern und die
Krankenkassen entlasten wer steht für
diese Bestimmung wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltenen Empfehlung gegen die Stimmen
der afd-fraktion wenn die Stimme
Fraktion des Hauses angenommen weiterhin
empfiehlt der Ausschuss und der
Buchstabe H seine beschissenempfehlung
die Ablehnung des Antrags der Fraktion
Die Linke auf Drucksache 3484 mit dem
Titel Kassen Defizite solidarisch
überwinden Erhöhung der Beitragssätze
durch die Krankenkassen verhindern wer
stimmt für die lösempfehlung
dass die Koalitionsfraktionen und
coc-situation bestimmt dagegen Fraktion
DIE LINKE wer enthält sich die Fraktion
der AFD dann ist diese
Beschlussempfehlung angenommen
schließlich empfiehlt der Ausschuss und
der Buchstabe i seine
Beschlussempfehlung die Ablehnung des
Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke auf
Drucksache 3485 mit dem Titel
Mehrwertsteuer auf Arzneimittel absenken
Anhebung der Zusatzbeiträge für
gesetzlich Krankenversicherte verhindern
wer stimmt für diese Empfehlung
wer stimmt dagegen Enthaltungen keinen
erst gegen die Stimmen der Fraktion Die
Linke die beschlossenen Fehler mit den
überstimmungen der Fraktionen des Hauses
angenommen